tell us about planning so pre-production
wearing both hats as the DP and the
director what are you doing beforehand
you know it's weird because for me this
is all only way I know how to do it
I've never only been the director of
anything I've never let somebody else
shoot a project that I was also
directing so I don't know the other way
I don't know how to do it the other way
I don't know how to think about how I'm
gonna direct it without thinking about
how I'm also going to shoot it so my
planning involves both pretty much
simultaneously and seamless seamlessly
really when I think about a scene I
visualize it like I'm looking at how it
will be shot already and that's almost
like at this point it's like riding a
bike to me I got even you think about it
on a detailed level about how something
is gonna be filmed and I kind of ran
into some issues early on because there
was an expectation to get storyboards
from me early on and I just again I
don't like doing what I don't want to do
and I felt storyboards are not necessary
because I'm the one shooting the film
also directing the film I didn't really
feel the need for that because it's
already like in my head you know what
I'm shooting when I'm reading a script
even when I read scripts that I'm just
gonna cinematographer on um while I'm
reading the script and it's playing out
in my head how it's gonna be shot there
might be small adjustments on the day
but for the most part it's already
pretty much shot in my head before we
even get to set so it's hard for me to
like
I had to defy had to ask that part of my
pre-production out because it took too
much time for me to physically sit there
and draw what my mind was thinking for
it would have taken me days to do this
and I I needed to spend that time as a
cinematographer and a director working
on other things so I didn't I didn't do
that and I didn't confuse people early
on because they didn't really understand
how my mind worked in that regard but
once we got on set and you saw how
things ran it was understandable I think
for everybody because it was just really
smooth sailing as far as the shooting
goes and when I'm in the middle of a
sequence and the thing about working
with such great actors is they will
bring stuff to the table and they'll
inject things into the scene that I
never could have thought of however
there's an energy to the way I film it
where I'm right there with them right
and as a director that helps me also
because I'm I'm literally like inches or
feet away from the actor while they're
doing their performance and I can feel
it I can feel the aura it's coming off
of them when they're doing their thing
and I take that and put it back into the
camera so I'm following I'm like right
there with and I'm attached to them with
that that energy and I think that's part
of my style and I can't really divorce
myself from that I don't think it's not
something I have the ability to separate
anymore it's just something that I need
to do I need to be operating the camera
if I'm the director because I can truly
watch it from an audience members
perspective by being that close to it
like just looking at a monitor of it
later like it's a different movie to me
when I'm seeing just flat images and I'm
not hearing their voice actually right
next to me I'm hearing it through a
microphone it's a different experience
for me than it is to be right there next
time feeling what they're doing
and translating that into what um
there's a there isn't a scene for
example where Musa Watson's characters
like barreling up the hallway and
everybody is running out of the room
trying to figure out what's going on why
he's shouting because he's got dementia
and he's just kind of like going off of
this ramble and it was like one of the
coolest single take shots I've ever done
as a cinematographer but Austin was a
director because I was literally right
in the scene with him and I was looking
with the camera at things that caught my
attention that I felt that audience
would probably want to look at if they
heard it so things were happening and I
was getting in the face of some of the
actors while they were doing their thing
and I was coming back out and I was
going around people and pulling focus
from one person to the other while
they're observing other people reacting
to things it's kind of like if I was
standing there myself which I was going
around and trying to notice the things
that I thought were the most important
in the scene I grab that with the camera
sometimes it's not always the person
talking but it's the person watching the
person talking and I was able to grab
that and this and I think the actors
like it too because they all have to be
on their game it's not just the person
speaking that has to be on their game
it's the person that's standing next to
them or the person that's behind them or
across from them I'm gonna get that
stuff if I think it's good and so the
actors want to give me more as a result
I think that's what they say to me at
least
maybe that's chaotic for them I don't
know but I feel like I get better energy
from them when I'm in the moment with
them and there's something satisfying to
me on personal level to when I'm you
know when they when they nail it and I
know that it's like a team I've heard me
like you know there's something to be
proud of there and I can make very small
minut character adjustments in this mode
because I can be right there looking at
what they're doing with their hand with
their eyes and taking all that in and I
can come up to them and privates
you know privately and just whisper a
little thing in their ear and they don't
they know exactly what I'm talking about
because they also know that I'm noticing
that and they're like oh
was that good I give them something else
next time so there's a little bit of I
keep them on their game by doing that I
think is there's less separation
I couldn't just be behind a monitor
shouting direction at someone or you
know that works for a lot of people but
I've never done that before so I don't
know how to do it that way so I guess
it's just it doesn't seem unusual to me
so you're like an empath with the camera
almost you're empathic you can feel yeah
my especially in this film I needed to
be able to glean as much emotion from
the characters as possible on the frame
because to me this film was more it was
important that the characters came
across very very well for the rest of
the story to work and needed to
understand their motivations and you
needed to understand their emotional
state in order to get the story and I
think because of that I really needed to
be involved and very close up with the
actors with the camera as often as
possible I've done films since then
which are not that way you know they're
more like a action movie for example and
I'd like to stay wider in action movies
because it's more about what's happening
physically in the frame rather than
emotionally or in someone pies you can
get to those moments in an action film
and it really helps to make the scenes
more intense and so I think I bring that
to the table with action movies as well
but in this film it wasn't so much about
the action there was about a lot of
action of course we did the fighting and
with Derek and Tyler but you know their
whole rest of the film is standing on
this emotion and this the relationships
and the characters so I had to figure
out a way to make that really
interesting and impactful because people
are so glossed over these days it's easy
to just not pay attention for a second
so you have to hit things a little bit
on the head sometimes people like and
get real close-up on it so they can know
that's important so if you don't show
that some time for you if if you know
it's important then you show it in a
medium shot or whatever it can easily be
slipping through the cracks for your
audience sometimes you have to really
get close and really show them things
you can do it in a way that's subtle
where maybe they don't notice it really
but subliminally they catch it because
you're like right up on it and I think
that's the beauty of the insert shot and
I learned that on this film how
important the insure shots are because
little details would slip through the
cracks of the audience sometimes and so
I throw that insert in there for a
second and they'd get it hit understand
it even if it was a subliminal
understanding but the scene felt
complete and so not only is being in
there with the actors and all that stuff
important but I would notice something
that they did with their hand or I've
noticed something that they did a
certain way where they would set the
cigarette and then you know they would
flick the ash of the cigarette I want
that little piece of detail that their
character is giving me because it's
important sometimes more than what
they're saying or what their face is
showing because they can they can be
providing the emotional cues and other
parts of their body as well so I guess
that's why I do it that's why I am a
cinematographer and a director because I
can be in there and notice those things
instead of just seeing only what is in
the frame I can look down there and see
what he's doing real quick and come back
to the frame I can be right up on it and
here's something that they said that
maybe wasn't coming through the mic or
whatever you know some people aren't mic
to know I was getting the full picture
when you're just sitting behind two
monitors or a monitor it's it's it's
hard I guess it's a complicated
explanation but when you ask me that I
had to think about it and that's really
what I think it comes down to is it's
easier to be
observant I'm that close to them
you